okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are doing a design meeting
talking about compatibility between a
variety of text image and other pieces
of functionality so Etienne were you
about to send me something to start off
with yep hey Steven we have also brought
Carlo in for the audio part okay which
doesn't exist yet but it will be good if
I am about what happens in tax case much
phases well and we want audio cases as
well so um all right well let's let's
start off looking at okay so out here
and has some comments here somebody has
a bunch of background noise sounds like
No who knows
okay so what we're dealing with here is
we've got text cases which has in this
case a sentence and a type so pick the
words from this okay several types okay
okay but now we've also got things like
don't we have the facial features type
thing where we have another pattern for
what to do with this how are we doing
that
who can is Julie oh here can you speak
yes yes probably fine faces is the one
that you want okay okay okay so I mean
the fundamental issue is there are
different things we want we might want
the position we might want the actual
contents there men so faces has as
properties here I see has bounding box
what is that is that the number of
pixels in the image in that region yes
yes and then there's all the features
available in fashion features are
supported here as well so question about
position like with images I thought
there are multiple coordinate systems
which one is this our standard image
coordinate system the one that is shown
in the first illustration up in the
notes 0 0 at the bottom left ok ok so
you're returning these rectangles yes
because why because this reason is
usable by other function that supposed
regions and we have also updated all the
image functions to take regions in so
like image stream highlight image they
all work with regions now you may move
with things like rectangle we also work
with disk and so on these point
everything we've added support for
constant region cue regions basically
connected regions defined without
parameters in the highlighting function
ok ok that's great
is it documented yeah really the
highlight image an image trim those are
gone
in the pipeline that they're gonna be
useful and we talk about that here yep
great great but I have a question which
is what is the animal way solve IT nudge
we're talking last time about you know
exploit maybe highlight text movie
better too much highlight image
I don't do I agree it depends what's in
it what do we think the actual design is
going to be well I guess it's going to
be a bunch of positions of the region it
should be highlighted and possibly some
labels so which I think a highlight
image has rights annotation that's right
exactly
URL yeah so so wait a minute so what we
imagine then I'm not keen on highlight
text I think it's a little bit obscure
but well text blood is also kind of
obscure what I'm imagining for text plot
is that there are more complicated
things we might do like you know
underlines and things like that you know
what I'm saying like like where we
highlight like we do in the case of text
structure see what I'm saying I mean one
style is pure highlighting right but
another style is some well I could be a
style of violating you know when you say
from this character to this character
and then you have a sort of property
which is like you know we want this is
so slow but but I mean look the basic
construction here is a labelled type
thing is what we is the similar thing
labeled or call out all of those things
need to be supported and those are plot
like creatures
I'll drop these in a light image now
look at the color tis not but the
annotation button
we tried Nate nope this morning that's
also supported maybe not documented
yeah but label label is in the design
yet because basically labeled and n'cole
out are as I said in the plot word what
this is basically graphics and there's
no generic supporting graphics for stuff
like labeled and allowed they just means
something inside the plot function
mm-hmm and it's a little bit unclear I
mean Cola will be very interesting for
images but it would have to be outside
of the image frame presumably yes I
thing I was explaining with was labeled
for stuff like image contents if you
want to highlight the bounding boxes and
automatically only four components and
it's not an image right a light image
output is a graphic now is it yeah okay
but but okay but so the the point here
is for text plot or highlight text by
the way do we have Brett here or not
yeah okay um do many grammar
talk about this them yes we should get
him okay no okay but let's go back to
our main main issue so okay so in image
cases what do we imagine okay you know I
am so how do I get a second you know
there we go great um
image cases is this is this current to
the document that's not built its future
is the opinions insidious yeah
okay this was basically modeled after
cases so returning a flat list of the
sub images that match the pattern of the
object that you put in second argument
okay but then we imagine that there will
be an image I mean are we imagining that
that there is also an image position
yeah basically image contents creates
every property and then you have
shortener functions like image position
image bounding box that can return
directly the property that you want so
unless a text analog of that sorry go
ahead
no there's none but but probably there
should so image content is a big
function for imagine image cases is just
a sub function of image contents for us
it would be text clearly already is a
big function maybe we should have a text
contents as well maybe I don't know if
that's a good baby yeah I mean we
haven't release image content so if you
want to adopt the design the like image
cases could change well text case has
been has been out long enough that we
shouldn't probably touch I like you know
sometimes I like image contents and the
fact that I said it looks nice you know
I think it's a bit more clunky to work
with afterward for practical
applications so I believe that most
applications are actually cases
for text for text and maybe for image
request would be the application well
I'll tell you that the application for
you know one thing is you see all these
at least demos of you know the
self-driving car that's labeling the
elephant crossing the road or whatever
yeah okay that actually but but but true
in that case it wants to know about
everything right because it okay it get
a bit undefined right at some point and
image you might have I mean on this
image you have just two things okay it's
pretty clear but at some point you might
start labeling oh sure sure sure that
but that's the that's the question of
what are you trying to get the cases of
in the image or the contents of in the
image by mean that the question is what
is the output right so I would say that
image position is I mean that's somewhat
useful it's like like you know let's
imagine you're trying to you've got a
series of frames in a video and you're
trying to track you know where did the
fall can fly or something right then you
want text image position I believe
exactly yeah if you want show me all the
Falcons in show me all the birds in the
picture you want image cases
and for image bounding boxes that's
mostly in a pipeline where you're going
to put labeling and things in I suspect
and in fact the question is for image
highlight I mean you know in a sense
show me all you know highlight all of
the you know elephants and the picture
or something right how would you do that
what's that what's the minimal pipeline
for doing that I think if we do support
operator form would be similar it would
be basically highlight image image comma
the image bounding boxes and like a let
me write let me write down which is ya
know you say highlight image suppose
functions in the second argument so you
can say image at first stablemaster oh
so basically every function is I don't
understand what is F G that's the
foreground but if you look at the first
table that says the region of interest
can be any of the following it can be a
region returned by a function f the last
entry of the table so will be image
image no no image first argument in the
image that you want to highlight and
then image bounding boxes and then
inside like elephant for example as an
operator form other yes does any of this
work by the way
nothing operator for my thing but I
don't think we have a better form of
bounding boxes but if you say image one
box is image comma elephant it will work
okay
I was giving some messages earlier today
from that this is 11 3 that I'm running
should I be running 12 no no this is in
the in master that hasn't changed
I don't know if we support anymore
though I have to see how the if you say
catch it one little with control eco I
think this is bit weird yeah if you put
the entity in is in Stefan community I
have to check the then alignment on the
identity why is it so slow okay so
there's the cat as a rectangle
interesting that's that's probably
reasonable although we've got other
don't we have other bounding box
we've got region bounds let's see what
what is the don't we have a Geo bounding
box and what does that return
interesting so yeah this is basically
the mean and like it would be the old
output with the mean I mean X mean Y max
Xmas why not just drop into position but
keep in mind that one reason why we
switch to rectangles and lines is that
especially these two objects you made
represent a line or a rectangle with two
X min x max one X min Y min xmax ymax
positions and it was difficult to keep
track of it now you can just stick this
rectangle or that line object in to
highlight image no no I agree I think
it's good and I also think it's good
that you don't necessarily you know that
one day we may have bounding boxes that
aren't purely rectangular yep yeah this
is one I mean that's kind of not the
point for geo bounding box because yeah
you know there is a boundary of Italy
but it's not rectangular but that's sort
of not the point but my question is
whether we could potentially sneak in an
additional argument
it's okay so there's the possibility of
actually let me just ask this question
do it do we have a project manager in
this meeting yes yeah okay because
there's going to be various different
pieces to pull together here so I think
that this is um
yeah I mean I'm kind of thinking geo
bounding box might need to have
something as image bounding boxes might
need to have that specifies what its
output
you know what style of output whether
it's geometric primitives or not it's
supposed to be did that make sense
see with this but might my next question
is in the case of text stuff the analog
of this decorated business is a text
element
it would be a span right start and end
position you think so right but what
about something more decorated like a
text element see the problem is that the
start end position hi okay text element
is very specific like if you want to do
different kind of highlighting like a
color or as I was saying underlying or
put a call out like it may be too
inflexible to use extremely full of it
fair enough so text position okay that
does that fine I think it's fine for
things I mean it's dimension so the
analog of that so image position we
called it positions I was just gonna
mention in one of the old meetings we
decided to your floral I wonder if that
utterly obscured this comma cat so
that's gonna give the meteorite of the
cat or something yeah exactly is this
the same point of the bunnies which in
this case is simple but it may get more
complicated if you know I think it is
user hostile to have an image
possessions plural well yeah yeah I
think because we mean we realize that
cases returns multiple things and
positions does the same thing but it was
already position either shuttle sailed
yeah let's change it to image position
ok I will do it um ok so ok so let's go
back over here
all right so so I was thinking text Keys
is I think it's pretty practical for
further applications we want to do like
it's an output that is easy to
manipulate especially with the change
that we did you know when there are
several types
now it's necessary on the other hand
when there several output property let's
say well let's take a look at what we've
got here so text cases of this let's say
you know verb noun and then can I say
animal don't know this version as
everything the next version wheel right
Church like try it and can I try it in
prototype or something is it submerged
things there are problems with done on
network it's nothing new but anyway it's
broken and prototype ok so I bet but you
think and if I get rid of the animal
here if you have the whole behavior
there why is it so unbelievably slow ok
but this is the old one you've changed
yeah yeah yeah I want to separate when
it's at least one to separate so we
surprised you know what can't see then
had branch build this was a working
prototype and also on the 12 sorry in
the 12 master what do you recommend head
branch or a prototype money any okay
we'll be interested to see how you do
the the two-dimensional thing when you
have both multiple like another way that
we have six million builds that's quite
impressive noticed seriously that's it
yeah it's that build number is six
million that's way too much I don't know
about that it just means we're testing a
lot it means like if we do three two
year it's like I don't know one falls in
the air or something like that yeah
what was that yeah well how many bill
are we doing it today
we're doing a few I think but but Tim
but those are that's not builds of
that's built since the beginning of the
build system so if we were releasing
every build then we'd be releasing every
few hours um okay so what you're doing
here why is this so slow okay let's run
of output yeah we always use this output
but it's a it's a case I didn't know you
sleep back put another sentence I don't
know I don't know whatever anyway a week
fixing is the new neuron that gonna fix
that I don't think for the parrot speech
as you know training path of speech but
I equal actually I mean normally they
are pretty good the power of speech
bread this what I were it's also um
that's freaking weird I don't know why
maybe they're all I mean walks was also
oh that's just crazy what why is it
Dhoni why is it not getting foxes a noun
and all that kind of thing no no it's
really broken well it alone that's your
thing yeah I will check what's up I mean
the accuracy and you know big this set
is pretty high in it well in this in
this particular example it's some not
working I don't know why I always use
this example what's that and okay so so
what's the outlook of this so in image
cases are you saying right right now
image cases if I were to do it for so in
this particular picture if you use it
for multiple categories it would be
similar as cases it would be flat it's
like prime or or integer it will just
you know distinguish between them
okay but but I think this case okay so
here's what I think we should do um okay
so this case I believe should do the
same thing that this one does because
remember that cases doesn't take the
list as cases will simply look for a
case see I think this is wrong I think
this should be cat arrow that guy dog
arrow that guy and the making sense
was to have this doing the same thing as
alternative because we do like I think
it's wrong
I think it's wrong because I think what
we want here is for cases itself right
in cases itself what we are doing is
something like this we've got you know
you know cases itself is looking for any
expression so it certainly doesn't use
the thing in you know if I if I give it
a different list it will be looking for
that literal list if you understand what
I'm saying yes yes do you think we still
want to support alternatives if you say
cut and we get the list of it case yeah
and in that case we get this but in the
case where there's a list here I think
what we want to do is give a an
association is output okay now the
interesting question is in this case at
least if we were to give I don't know
whether we should allow the abuse of
notation of saying verb vertical bar
noun we certainly should allow that for
for the entities I guess we can sort of
do this sort of whatever it is it works
what's that it's all set that seems
right yes well okay fair enough I just
am not wild about having alternatives
with with the strings like that but okay
fair enough
okay so we've agreed that then if
there's a list here it will turn into an
association form if there's an
alternatives it will stay in the list
form okay so let's go back over here
before we drop this there's one more
case here like 111
extra little complication because you
have Tex cases Foreman property so what
happens now to discuss that yeah okay
okay so then very quickly are we sure
for the alternative case we want to get
rid of the keys yes yeah I think is a
single object you say like if it's a cat
or a dog
I just want any that much the same if
you just do now it will it won't give it
I think it's good okay so in text cases
we have this idea of the property as
well so this a little bit stimulate okay
is actually when you have arrow except
we don't love the idea yeah yeah that
was our idea so accept that okay so what
can be on the right-hand side there
string position interpretation in case
that it's you know Oct or whatever okay
so and you can do the default the
default is string in that case right yep
default E string well I have to say I'm
I'm so partial to doing something
similar with image cases which we're not
doing right now right no because they're
the property thing he was in image
contents but yeah it's not difficult to
implement well maybe we don't I mean I
don't know whether we want it there so I
mean the thing with image cases I could
imagine like interpretation being useful
if you were using alternatives for
example you could certainly have
interpretation mean something
and if
should be a generic category yeah in
fact what you should be able to do here
is to say in which cases of that picture
, animal okay so let's let's consider
this case animal arrow interpretation
right and then what you should get out
is cat and dog
I believe wait waiting because if you
see any more like we are living on
ontology graph here yeah so are they we
introduced something else which is not a
member of the ontology graph or animal
will be interpreted as any class in the
animal category so this will give a list
of cats and dogs as images and then what
kind of interpreter do you want to call
on them it's a bit like applying image
identify on the result exactly exactly
exactly - right why not why not imaging
defy them well interpretation is going
to identify only deals with one object
exactly yeah but you're running it on
sub images right so I think the
right-hand side would be an arbitrary
function image identify similar possible
right I don't think that's quite the
right fingers if you if you do this
and I say country
great unimpressive
Wow why didn't that work this is rather
unimpressive what this will be fixing it
was a previous version it was based on
spitting so you need to match whatever
but okay so yeah they don't have it what
yeah it's not a new version yet okay
this is the old stuff
okay so that first one there
oh who knows what that is but but um I
probably will work in the old version
over here but you get what I'm saying
that that version the previous version
was just giving the analog of the images
right but this is giving the entities
for them see this is just the raw string
effectively which is like the raw image
the cat and the dog but this is now
giving the interpretation of those
things which did you care what I'm
saying yes but this okay then we need
not to allow people to use strings as
classes if we want to reserve them for
me interpreter types because here you
mean the interpreter type is country but
in me by classes which classes I mean
when you say anymore you are you are
referring to a specific here you are
both referring to an interpreter class
and a node on the ontology graph I'm not
significant it could be all the children
of any more on the ontology graph
exactly so I'm not sure if you want to
allow them to be both why no they should
they should align correct I mean that is
what we're saying is image cases I want
to know what are all the animals in my
picture okay so one way I want to get
that is as a bunch of images here are
the animals go identify them the other
one is give me the interpretation of
each of these animals
like
I don't know I mean another question
yeah that's how did you do with
interpreter classes because they try
every time I try to approach it is very
complex and deep issue and it's very
difficult to get actually what are their
in they what are the least of them for
example ok countries is easy but it's
not clear to me any black what LDL em
South Europe South Europe for example I
mean actually I don't even know if we
have that in some form but what were the
example South Africa and I it was a
concrete yes right we thought of a guy
is a country but but their country class
I don't know which example you mean I
don't know like like g8 countries or
something that will be a country class
I'm not a freak area so I said so which
was a country but today but I see it
when Sergio question so we are just
calling the interpreter in takes cases
and actually some idea because it can
fail also like you can recognize
something as a country but their
interpreter given the database it cannot
interpret it so you should flag those
cases and we should fix the linguistic
definitely you remove class the entity
class you don't you told me actually
this morning for the leveling task
remove them but they are in the model
I'm sorry back to this question if the
neuron that says it's a country you know
the code tree of Moldavia or something
which isn't a real country right but it
sort of thinks it's close enough to a
country but then our interpreter runs
and it fails you know Moldova would work
but Moldavia wouldn't yeah there's de
faria I was talking about like you are
not guarantee that you're gonna
interpret like it can be an imaginary
country and given the semantics you
against that is to contribute it will
hear a failure object so it won't crash
or you know I mean oh that's pretty
weird
frankly that's pretty weird I mean
the case where you say arrow
interpretation I think it should prune
it you know that if you say and so the
question is what look we've got two
kinds of inconsistency one inconsistency
would be you might have a different
number of things if you just said give
me the raw strings versus give me the
interpretations sir I'm saying but then
what if you ask for two properties yes
for position and interpretation then you
drop you'd have to prune completely if
the interpretation failed I mean you'd
have to say and arguably there could be
a method option to text cases that
basically says should you check the
interpretations see what I'm saying so
the method option would determine
whether it I mean it's similar to you
know when we do equation solving there's
an option which says do you want to you
know substitute in the solutions to
check they work type thing
yeah the pruning is a bit is be pretty
mighty because sometime you're also
asked for the string on the position and
interpretation and you know
yeah you should prune I'm saying you
should prune all of them all three of
them if the interpretation
look what I'm suggesting is that there's
a method option for text cases which
says I don't know what require
interpretation or something hmm um and
if that's on I'm not that's not probably
the right way to set up the method
option but something like that if that's
on then it will always check even if
you're only asking for string it will
check that there is an interpretation
there and will prune it otherwise
so let's go back to the image position
case or or a niche case this case okay
so if we're gonna do this thing with the
right hand side of image cases which I
kind of support then you know we can do
all of those things we can do you know
we might as well do all the things so
then what's the role of an inch contents
in that situation
unlike the obsolete I'm not sure it's
obsolete I mean first for humans for
just you know let's play nice
exactly just just to be able to see
everything you can also figure out what
to ask for
in image cases you know yeah you say
what's in either oh it can recognize
these in these oh I'm going to quite a
program within of cases that looks for
this dynamic cases better support all of
these and by the way I think this should
reorder and I think the the image should
come first here
agree
and the same sorry concept then then
bounding box
sure yeah okay though it's just not for
me to go there is no particular order I
say and and I think based on what we
discussed for facial features and
implement it we won't return a data set
by default just a list of associations
and then slice slash data set to display
why do we want to do that it was your
suggestion when we implement the facial
features I don't think we have to do it
exactly the same this is a Content
function and I think this like the text
search functions and things I think it
should return a data set I like that too
actually and I think it could be the
same way stacks like text contents the
NIE that I said gives everything I mean
many stuff should have a mess and text
case is is a payload function for the
real application it could be you don't
need to do everything I mean we support
for somebody official features we
decided that automatic and all our
different set of properties so for
example automatic could be image concept
and bounding box you could drop
dimension position probability and then
and then you go or just maybe just image
concept and probability if you prefer
and and then you can always query for
specific properties or say home and you
get the food actually I think the ones
that are interesting are image image
contact sex position and probability
that seems like the right ones to me so
image concept position probability
okay I think so
okay just to bring back some discussions
from the return type of facial features
extracting parts of a data set keeps
returning a data set and that's often
annoying for further processing but if
you think the image contents is just
gonna be this display function then I
agree the data set is rather yes I think
facial features the point with facial
features is that the most common thing
to want to do is well let's see I mean
it's to get what is about to happen by
the way when are we getting these these
boxes all standardized switch when is
that your project or whose project is it
is mine we're waiting on tally and he
promised me he will do he will like the
description this week before he goes to
summer school so he's not coming to
summer school he got exiled again sues
Lee okay
his visa thing was denied somehow how
that kind of happened I have no clue but
anyway so he's not okay somehow so that
my folds are loading in his data it's
one women my fault is a very classical
one it's a building classifier that
shows I think we need a we need a global
way to control
and with a global variable or something
to Detective wait because you know it's
a function that uses all the function
that uses all the function and some way
like this the initialization data the
fact that it says repository is a little
weird
well the lower level one is a second one
so we should keep just the first one but
it's true in practice the second one is
more informative yeah but I think the
only thing that's wrong with it is the
fact that it says downloading content
from the repository in the middle is
true because basically facial features
we decided to form classify in order not
to have any any duplication and classify
is downloading a neural network ok fine
but but it should just say I downloading
content is a completely obscure it
should say downloading network or
something from you know we cannot look
into that I think this is a generic the
generic well then that it should be
privatized Apple yeah then we should get
the resource system folk to prioritize
to allow privatization of that and how
many of these am I having to load this
is the thing that you've managed to find
a way to compress this network greatly
right yeah I mean Sebastian has proposed
this new model but as soon as we have
time we would like to be trained so
instead of having 500 megabytes network
which would be maybe 15 or 20 you know
that's really worthwhile because this
right now is completely unwieldy almost
certainly not work with an instant api
totally instant here right because it's
going to need to be unless it's pre
provisioned ah this is really boring
ok I'm I thought I was just going to get
an instant answer here
why I'm also I mean I must have used
this on this machine but I think metals
were updated recently okay
we're all redeployed at least I'm not
really following that's close near but
okay fair enough
well I think this is perfectly useful
and I think this is more agree with you
that this is more useful because the
typical thing you're gonna want to do is
to somehow you know is to say you know
hash age amperes and slash you know the
thing that is really kind of scary about
these things is that I think this these
norm that things are better at figuring
out ages than I am which is
bad no don't worry the aging Network is
hell it's really bad
no that doesn't mean but I may be even
worse I think as one gets all though it
becomes more and more difficult to
distinguish ages that are far from one's
own emotion are not so great either I
mean the second one is obviously happy
as well
oh I don't know I think that person is
skeptical I think it's fake smiled but
that's not good that I mean they okay
so all right so what we think what we're
agreeing is that the cases family will
have right-hand sides that are at least
strings whether we allow the slightly
bizarre thing of having a function on
the right-hand side which is what you're
doing in which function was that that
you had the foreground thing in shaadi
no that was highlight image but we
there's no arrow syntax we we thought
about that as well with Jerome for text
cases and we saw some use case
like let's say you want to you know the
string and then our arrow and the
position so it wouldn't be a function
that apply only on the string it will be
a function that apply on an association
where you have the string the position
so for example here you could put if you
open two parentheses string arrow
position if you see what I mean I was
happy I I guess I mean I mean but that
was an idea anyway that the right hand
side could be a function that will be
applied to essentially the virtual
Association that was generated
right this is this is the conceptual and
Association that's generated yeah that's
that's one way there's one level
difference here and is that the image
age gender is basically on the same side
as the interpretation position and
string
yes so but you you don't have double
association yeah you don't have an
excellent situation again
you just have an association for like
yes yes yes
so entities to be Twitter because it
doesn't generate this association at
level two okay look what do you mean it
doesn't generate a level two I mean it's
gonna be the only thing if I say country
comma date or something it's gonna give
an association of yes yes level one
interpretation comma string it's wrong
even Association there it'll give us a
list there at least yeah yeah right so
so one of the questions would be if I
want something at that level that it's
more of a structure yeah I see what
you're saying
I see what you're saying you're saying
that those things there if I gave okay I
get it so let's imagine this right here
um you're saying if what I did there
instead was something like hash
interpretation arrow hash string
ampersand right that you would apply
that function to the to the pop-up
Association so to speak that's like this
actually
yep yeah and so the Matiz would be
available like instead of image you
would have repetition age you have
string and identity which on this yeah I
was gonna say especially for single
property cases like you only ask for
image or bounding box then then we can
just have single op single functions
specified on the right-hand side well or
in particular you can just have this
syntax here where that is equivalent
where that syntax is equivalent to you
know hash interpretation comma
string
Amazon right yeah exactly yeah well
that's not stupid
seems quite sensible actually the
advantage of this would be that it's a
perfect place to put some quick
post-processing yeah word translation or
some you know just like II imagine that
you what you want this to string split
on to do character the character of the
string if you want to do that afterwards
you have to map at the second column
well in this case it just specified
directly yeah okay well I don't reject
to this but okay so what have we so um
the
let's see what what are we doing here so
we've got to have the question is what
possible forms are there for text cases
and we have that list and and what
possible forms are there for image cases
or for audio cases for that matter and
for text cases obviously we what in test
case is a string in image cases is image
and it would similarly be audio
presumably for the audio case right yep
now in the audio case are you imagining
that you know you're saying that you're
dealing with with classes like dog bark
and things that's what you are asking
for for audio cases because I would more
think that what you'd want there and
actually I guess this is the question
for image cases as well you know what I
really want is to use sort of pop up
training in image cases to say look for
sub images that are like this right that
was the function that we talked about
last time that was the subject sub
casing function remember right but that
was the alternative tooth pattern object
because what we've what we've understood
is that image identify right is the
whole object identification right but
what we also think we want is a partial
object as the solution was going to work
or not
then um oh for goodness sake oh great
well okay fair enough okay so then the
question is
okay what are we doing
image cases asks for a specific
um type of thing in the image whereas
image contents is going to tell me this
is I glasses face etc etc etc presumably
yep
okay and in the case of text contents
it's going to give a great big long
analysis of the piece of text probably
because text contents I don't you've
even thought about how to do that but
text contents would be unnaturally
saying well what are all the possible
that's a perfectly reasonable thing I
mean it's some of the what the wolf
Natha posit does is asking what are all
the possible entities that are contained
in Hill all the things you know what's
everything that is identifiable in the
text if you understand what I'm saying I
guess we'll take the ID that you was
talking about like the all automatic I
think so yeah
sorry Knight probably its entity
identification you want to do and a few
other things you probably don't want to
do nouns and verbs
okay but what was the sub K Singh
function that we were talking about
before what was the function for looking
that is the our log of this but it looks
for sub pieces here pirate cases what's
that did we talk about something like
part cases yeah that's what we were
talking about right to be come up with a
better name than that okay I mean we
came up with names we were not happy
with okay but I mean in in but
essentially what we're saying here is
part cases um see image cases is
automatically apart cases so to speak
but the thing it isn't doing okay so the
question is what's the answer to the
question of how do you feed it a
collection of images and say you know I
want to find places in the image that
match a thing that looks like this
right that was the image pattern type
thing right
yes yes yeah okay so what do we think
we're doing with that I mean
happy about it well what what's let's
discuss I mean that this is saying this
is kind of a pop up classifier no simply
I mean I'm
about it I mean terms of implementation
there will be some tricky things because
when okay when you create a mesh pattern
you might want to do some pre-processing
I took we have to do it later several
times on the other hand you need to know
the type the task that will you know you
need Aloha why this image pattern will
be used for in order to know what time
he was saying you need to do so it's if
it's always used in image cases then
it's not much of a problem okay here's
my suggestion my suggestion is that
image Pat pattern if it can do
pre-processing okay could we not have a
a a cached extra element like we doing
things like rule okay here's a crazy
idea right you do it in image cases the
image pattern adds to itself a hidden
cached lump of stuff that is the
pre-processing it did for image cases
use it somewhere else says well that
pre-processing isn't useful to me I need
to do it again it adds another piece of
pre-processing from whatever it was used
for there you have to keep both the
original content and all the
pre-processing both shown that's right
well yes but I wouldn't store it you
know I wouldn't serialize that I would
just have that be a maybe
I mean mate bro maybe you do want to do
that maybe you want image pattern to
actually return I'm not sure not sure
now I think I mean this should
definitely be this would be in a summary
box I think where evaluated or something
like that so the the content will not be
in a notebook most definitely I think
the choice is if we want to just have it
in memory so that means up to you to
save it or not or it has to be something
like a local object I'm not very
familiar with those actually that's a
big mess to do it that way I don't think
you want to do that it depends how big
it is it's like a classifier function
more it's like like maybe
you know you want to see create a
partial object of you know your son so
you take 100 pictures and you have all
those 100 pictures plus all the
classifiers that you define all the
things I start to identify I'm not sure
like if you want to like 80 and like if
you want to create multiple features you
need to keep the data somehow yeah hello
so you're claiming that even with our
feature extractors and transfer learning
and so on that the thing to recognize a
particular face is a fair amount of data
that what you're claiming know is that
if you want to use it what it was saying
is that if you know that you're going to
use that object to recognize faces you
can extract a specific set of features
but if you don't want to use it in
another function then it's not
guaranteed that you I mean right now we
cannot refer like we're not mean invert
the feature extraction structural
process so like we are stuck with with
face features that maybe are not good to
do in I am yeah what your saboteur there
is a generic set of features that we are
typically using an image cases I mean
image cases might have a feature
extractor that it uses perhaps I don't
know even know does it have that as an
option
not really right now no this is not
implemented we have the image field
instructor and that that is the kind of
a standard instructor the the thing with
the faces was for a fight for example
that if you extract the juice with a
facial thing to extract or you get
better recognition but at that point
everything I understand that but so in
general for image pattern it would seem
to me I mean clearly you might in
principle have a facial pattern but I
think that gets a little weird like that
gets too complicated but what I would do
is have a front you know a triage thing
that says is it a face are these all
faces are they narc images but no very
importantly it's a very all faces in the
pattern and in the image to be tased so
to speak because if you have a bunch of
face in the pattern and you extract the
feature with a face feature extractor
but then in the image you have a bunch
of trees and whatever
that will be all extracted with the
image with the feet with the face
feature extractor and this may get very
bad result I look like a koala hiding in
the tree oh you'll also get the Koala
maybe or all tree looks like a face in
the face face feature space you know
like another face you mean you see what
I mean so you know I understand but what
I'm saying is if if the steps are is
triage that determines what type of an
image it is okay here's my suggestion
okay if image Pat so image pattern needs
a certain amount of automation here the
first thing that's got to do is to
triage and say okay what type of an
image is this is that a face or is it a
general image let's say right assuming
those are the two cases that we're gonna
deal with right it's a face okay
then in the main casing and the main
cases thing it's going to have those two
steps that is it's going to say I'm only
gonna look for faces and then I'm going
to apply the features that I've got from
the face
of premieres pattern yeah that would
work
I think that's I mean I think we need to
think of image pattern as kind of a
super function that is going to be able
to tell other functions how to behave
basically I mean we also have a very
strong we don't evaluate image pattern
so we don't pre compute stuff and to be
finer
to do what so the rapper
function around it is going to determine
how to how to extract features
well yes that's fine I mean look the
image pattern will look just like an
image pattern here but it might happen
to have some stuff inside it as well
that it can use for you know for
convenience if it finds that it's useful
that is if the image cases on the
outside finds that the image pattern has
you know pre cached information then um
uh you know then it just does its thing
okay let's talk about um oh I noticed we
have some questions on our live stream
here which will answer for yes it uses
no one that's to download image to
classify images don't CNN's reduce the
size of no that's no no these are this
is using that's just for fun show
actually I'm curious about this let me
look at the the actual network where do
we have then that model do we have the
facial with the facial recognition
network in that model
I'm not sure what is the facial
recognition network oh you want one that
gets a property of a face yeah
what is that cold do we have many it in
your rent I mean there's a age one so
take exactly edge estimation but we
didn't obviously this wasn't well no
well can I interrupt this yep just abort
you
this one here yep okay
so this is the thing that there is now a
more efficient version of
for the person asking a live stream
there are as you can see there are many
convolutions here
does that does the new one is the new
one fewer layers right now there's no
new network the endless rhythm Sebastin
last week was proposing that we use this
new model but it's it's anything that
means big crunchy creature look at that
yes
five thousand dollar vector Wow
that's probably where all most of the
size of the network is actually in what
in that linear layer after that big
number hmm okay well anyway all right
but but okay so back to audio for a
second
so we're imagining that there will be an
audio pattern like this is that right
where you would be able to give I mean
the thing that's tricky about this this
is the similar to the problem of you
know you let's say you give samples of
different people's voices here or of a
particular person's voice there that
would be the audio pattern that would
then you could then use where where it
would I mean okay the issue is what is
it recognizing right it's a particular
person's voice or it's the person when
they are happy versus not happy or
whatever else it needs to as you're
saying a ten it needs to know the
context to know to know what features
it's supposed to pick out although I
think this hierarchy approach is not
completely silly that is it says you
know it knows it has to drill down to a
certain level you know I I mean call
away comment on this good I mean okay
just refused on that when we'll have
learn distribution working well images
then we won't have this problem anymore
anyway because it will be reversible
feature extractor it won't be fooled by
its not just a projection you know we
kind of keep the noise and I mean anyway
that that might not even happen in the
next year or two so what wait
conceptually if you have a feature
extractor that preserves information yep
then you wouldn't be fooled if I give a
tree to expect all the specifics of
it won't be fooled because the noise
will get crazy basically that was this
weird reversible a place exactly exactly
which I hope that we can do nice thing
with it but you know really I mean you
know in some remote future okay fair
enough okay
so as for audio as it can and Julie was
saying actually refer for images there
in the case where all of this feature
extraction happens in in this case in
audio cases rather than in audio pattern
then it makes sense but it is a bit more
problematic to do feature extraction in
audio pattern because what kind of space
you will extract your features in will
depend on what problem you are
investigating so sentiment age speaker
identity it is very much analogous to
what we were discussing with image by
the way somebody on the live stream is
asking about capsule networks and I
think we just added a bunch of capsule
networks to the know on that repository
didn't we yeah I mean there is one where
is it at least so I can call them second
entry caps caps net there we go cool I
chant curse what this thing is like um
okay this is irrelevant though that's so
well it's small
at least it's what's us it's eight
layers but I guess each layer maybe you
know I don't know yeah it's more like
right right now is basically doing what
letís do interests in a more complicated
way it's constructed very interesting
but we can click on so we see what's
inside
yeah I see there's layers inside layers
so that's a big man there's a net graph
again if you look in the second one it
music Casper audio has just been
published that would be in points we get
to it um you know the way these neural
nets look at this stage in in history is
just so much like you know low-level
circuit diagrams and so on I mean
there's got to be a high level way of
representing this stuff anyway
just um
okay so we need to wrap up here really
late on a bunch of things but let's some
so I think we have a path forward do you
think we answer the questions that we
started out with here
um so the only we haven't addressed text
plot and I'm not sure we have do we have
the relevant people here for that I
don't see right here so okay okay fine
okay but just a very quick comment on
the planning function Carla and I have
been talking about some sort of a
dynamic audio plot and I think that
would be relevant for text flawed as
well so that you just stream and plot
events or detections or or whatever else
some annotations gonna cool it's like
you know forget teleprompters we can
just have a streaming text plot I mean
that's what you're suggesting but it's
like a it's like a pick a type of text
mm-hmm is that actually useful
normally sorry go ahead
notice that with closed captioning
people do not do that um in other words
it could be the case that when you did
closed captioning that there would be a
a caption that runs across the bottom of
the screen but people don't do that they
do boom boom boom
you know one sentence at least I've
never maybe i'm just don't watch the
right things but right it's not the UX
that people like to have where you have
a video and you have a sort of ticker
tape going underneath as opposed to just
one caption then the next caption then
the next caption did that make sense
and that might be one mode or the
preferred mode of the dynamic text and
dynamic audio plus but but the main idea
is that the idea in text is one
dimensional both and then could be very
long yeah already text cases that is
beyond the couple of sentences becomes
very a very complicated structure yeah I
know but I mean having it dynamically
stream by just seems crazy or maybe with
a slider go through and I think people
want to I mean people want to see text
in two dimensions which is fine that's
how you
it's been formatted since people were
you know writing on Scrolls and things I
mean right it's a text is
one-dimensional but it's chopped into
lines and put on a page which in the
case of audio one does not normally do
although one could it certainly sees
that and I don't know what I've seen
that in um like in neuron recordings and
things like that I think I've seen a
thing where you we have multiple lines
and it's chopped I mean I think the main
problem with audio and you know is what
do you show you show a waveform or
something but that's not something that
most people I mean you know again like
yeah the seismograph traces are often
chopped like that right because it's
mostly boring but then suddenly
something happens um
caller do you want to comment on this I
mean what what is the use case the the
use case
so I think well the reasoning behind a
dynamic plot for audio with another the
main the main event would not be
displaying the content of audio because
I mean you either have a wave form of a
spectrogram and those are not overly
informative yeah for the average user
the idea was to use this as a tool to
display annotations that a user either
computed or manually inserted mm-hmm so
I'm just I'm listening to the tech that
the audio go by and every so often a
word flashes up on the screen if that is
done with a patient that you have but
you could annotate I don't know
sentences you can annotate transient
events like a speed or something like
that right but wait a minute an
annotation the annotation of speakers is
much more something like what we're
doing a text structure where you have a
narrative but no I know actually the
right way to do that is what people have
done for you know sort of screenplays
for ever and I would you know play
scripts for plays and things forever and
ever
right it's little or you know or legal
transcripts depositions whatever they
are you know it's like this person :
blah blah blah blah blah I mean that's
presumably the kind of output we want
yeah but the idea is that we would like
to be able to display a generic
annotation these are just some specific
examples another one could be defined
the transcription of the fundamental
frequency of the signal so this is very
much a different beast so we're trying
to find a way of just displaying and uh
notated or play an annotated audio and
show the annotation yeah I don't think
we have clear ideas on how that should
look like yet um the main point is we
have annotations on a signal how is how
does the user interact with them
sorry sorry I'm distracted here um say
that again good so we have annotations
on an audio object that could be either
automatically computed or the user has
input at some point how does the user
interact and visualize these annotations
I don't know how does it work in typical
audio editing programs it is very clunky
one example that is very much used for
speech related stuff is Pratt and it
displays as usually a spectrogram and
then a lot of these annotations are
either text or just values as a function
of time and it displays statically a
series of rows and each row has an
annotation it is a bit clunky I think
this is a separate discussion yes so
let's let's have a separate discussion
about essentially text plot and audio
plot well we already have an audio plot
but um ah whatever this is going to be
um and let's see somebody was asking on
the livestream why aren't image cases
that image cases in which bounding box
are in 11 3 but are not documented yep
well you're kind of seeing why they're
not documented which is we haven't
completely figured them out you're fine
with image cases in 11 3 that it does
work but it doesn't know very many
classes of objects this is a reason why
it's not documented yet right right okay
anything else we absolutely have to do
right now ok great Sushma do you want
these notebooks did I do anything
important in these notebooks I have
taken notes but you can send it to me to
save them oh yeah there is a neural net
framework folder under SW nodes
ok all right also not ok ok thanks
thanks
I know pilot